U.S President Joe Biden on Tuesday
dedicated a new National Monument to
Emmett Till and his mother Mamie till
Mobley today
on what would have been Evan and
Emmett's 82nd birthday
we had another chapter in the story of
remembrance and healing Emmett Till was
just 14 years old when in 1955 in
Mississippi he was abducted tortured and
murdered by two white men they killed
him accused him of whistling at a white
woman Till's funeral made Global
headlines when his mother insisted on an
open casket more than a thousand people
attended the church service for till
while thousands of others listened
outside the men responsible for Till's
murder were acquitted by an all-white
jury they later confessed to The Killing
The Monuments honoring till are in
Mississippi where the killers were
acquitted and Illinois where till grew
up even as this White House honors the
till family Legacy racial tensions
persist some U.S politicians say it's
time to move on and focusing on the past
racial injustices is a mistake since
2020 more than 40 States particularly
those controlled by Republican
legislatures have placed restrictions on
the way America's racial past is taught
in schools
if Florida Governor Ron DeSantis signed
a law called the stop woke act requiring
States authorization for books among the
banned titles are books about racism and
African-American history we've enacted
protections for parents such as
curriculum transparency so that they
have a right to know what books are
being used and what curriculum is being
taught to their kids
more recently teachers in Florida have
been told to teach some of the so-called
positive benefits of slavery at a time
when there are those who seek to ban
books
Barry history
we're making it clear crystal clear
the darkness and the nihilism can hide
much
they erase nothing but the legacy of
racism in America persists despite
ongoing efforts to overcome it ignited
by the mother of a 14 year old boy
determined to transform her grief into
good Kimberly halket Al Jazeera the
White House
foreign